This is a great day.
We're having our second
lecture on glass,
and we've got a demo--
where did Peter go?
So we've got a demo
coming up for you
from the director of the
glass blowing lab here at MIT.
And now before we
start, I just want
to mention, so next Monday--
so we're going to talk today--
we're going to continue
what we started, which
is the chemistry
of glass, and we'll
talk about that cooling curve or
the effects of different things
on the glass formation
and then how to engineer
the properties of the glass.
Before I start, I just want
to mention that next Monday we
have something called
the Wulff Lecture.
And this is a lecture that
is open to the public.
It's geared towards freshmen.
It's put on by the Department
of Materials Science
and Engineering every
year, and it's usually
some sort of really interesting,
exciting topic and usually
a very dynamic lecture.
And in this case it's one of
our very own, Sam Shames, who
graduated in 2014, and he'll
be talking about his adventures
as a material
scientist and how he's
used that knowledge in his
life and also in the company
that he founded which is now
selling products in over 70
countries around the world.
So I think that will
be a lot of fun.
If you can make it, it's next
Monday from 4:00 to 5:00 PM.
All right, now the second
point I want to make
is that there's a mistake
on tomorrow's quiz,
just in the schedule.
So quiz number
eight will be given
at the beginning of class.
Quiz eight is at beginning
of class, not the end.
I think it might
mistakenly say the end.
So you might notice
sometimes the quiz--
so tomorrow the quiz is going to
cover defects and then whatever
was covered up until Monday's
lecture and Tuesday's
recitation, which includes
the beginning of what
we talked about--
[DINGING]
OK, let's not do that.
Let's turn that off.
And we had an exam on a
Monday, and so we didn't want
to give you a quiz that week.
So we're doing defects tomorrow
even though we covered defects
last week.
And then we didn't want
to give you a quiz right
before or on Thanksgiving.
That didn't seem right.
So for the next quiz
what we're doing is
we're still making a
quiz for you to have,
and we're going to give
it to you next week
but we're not going to count it.
So next week you
will still get a quiz
that you have for your studying
because I know you'll miss it.
But in case you're
not here or you
don't want to do the
quiz over your turkey,
we're not going
to count that one.
So quiz nine won't be counted.
All right, so
that's the quizzes.
Now, where were we?
Here we are.
Speaking of quiz material
and thinking about glass
as a potential problem
on tomorrow's quiz, yes.
You might want to know
about some of the things
we talked about Monday.
Here's an example.
OK, here's a question.
I have two glasses.
They form from liquids,
and they're cooled
to some temperature I call T1.
And I tell you
that T1 is greater
than Tm, which is the melting
point of the material.
Now remember, the melting
point is the same.
It's a number.
The melting point of
silica, that's a number.
But when the material
forms a glass can vary.
Why does a glass form?
Well, a glass forms--
this is what we
covered on Monday-- it
can form because of three
different things, right?
One is the crystal complexity.
That's important.
Another is the viscosity.
And the third is
the cooling rate.
Those are the three
things that we covered
on Monday for reasons
why a glass might form,
and then we started kind of
talking about the cooling rate.
That's what we
need to understand
to answer this question.
So, OK, two glasses
forming liquids.
One glass is formed.
Plot the molar volume
versus temperature.
All right, so now, let's see.
How about this?
Could this be the volume
per mole versus temperature?
So I'm going to try it out here.
I'm going to go like this.
I'm going to go like this, and
that looks like the liquid,
maybe.
And then I'm going to go
like this and maybe this,
and we'll call that T1.
Does that look right?
No, this can't be right.
This can't be right because,
you see, I said that T1,
this is a glass transition.
That's a glass transition.
That's a Tg.
That's another Tg.
But I've said in the question
T1 is greater than Tm.
Well, so this can't be true
because Tm has to be out here.
Tm is out here where there's
a different transition that
occurs, and it turns
into a crystal.
So this couldn't be
right, T1 greater than Tm.
So what about another one?
Let's try another one.
So how about if I--
OK, volume per mole.
Now I'm going to go like this.
So I'm going to go like this.
So now here comes one,
and here comes the other.
And OK, so I'm going
to put now T1 maybe--
let's try T1 is going to be
out here, and Tm would be--
actually, let me
do it differently.
Sorry.
I'm going to go like this.
I'll just connect-- how
do I want to do this?
I want it to join
these up there.
Yeah, that's another
good mistake.
I'm making mistakes on purpose.
And let's make T1 be out here.
So T1 is here, and then
Tm could still be there.
This could be Tm.
And then maybe is that right?
Is that a possible curve?
Well, that fixed
the T1-Tm problem
because T1 is now greater than
Tm like I said in the question,
but what is going on here?
What is going on?
You say, well, but I cooled
one faster than the other.
Isn't that kind of
what's happening here?
Maybe I started
changing the curve?
No.
That's not what this is,
so don't make that mistake.
You see, remember, the slope is
equal to the thermal expansion
coefficient--
thermal expansion coefficient.
And those slopes are the same
for the different glasses.
Just because I've
cooled one differently,
they're not going to
have different slopes.
And this is the
fundamental challenge.
This is the fundamental
confusion point
that happens which is
that this is not time.
This axis is not time.
So this is wrong to.
What we're doing is we're
talking about something
involving time, cooling rate.
But we're plotting
it on something
that doesn't involve time, and
that can lead to confusion.
So I wanted to point that out.
You say, well,
shouldn't the slope
be different because you're
cooling it slower or faster?
No, that's not
what this slope is.
This slope is a thermal
expansion coefficient.
So the right answer
to this must be
that you have your
nice liquid phase
and you've made
your two glasses.
So here's one.
This has cooled faster.
This is slower.
This would be Tg.
This would be another
Tg, maybe Tg1, Tg2.
And the Tm would
come down and have--
well, I've run out
of room here, but Tm
might come down like this.
And so T1 must be
somewhere up here.
That would be a correct
plot for that question.
So does everybody see?
I just want you to get
a feeling for this plot.
We introduced it
Monday, and I really
want you to feel your
oneness with this plot
because it's a
very important plot
to understand why glasses form.
All right, now
moving on, there's
a lot of properties of
glasses, and here I'm
talking about oxide
glasses, so silica.
Remember, silicon oxide,
oxide, silica, alumina.
These are, oh, oxide.
We talked about that.
Chemically inert,
electrically insulating,
mechanically brittle,
optically transparent,
visually arresting--
I like that one--
these are the
properties that we know
about these kinds of glasses.
We already know them.
But what I want to
talk about today
is how they can be engineered.
And this plot is a basis
for understanding that.
And so is spaghetti, and that's
what we're going to talk about.
So the very first one--
which we'll set up
our demo in just a few minutes.
The very first one that
I want to talk about
is the mechanical properties.
We know glass to
be very brittle,
but could we change its
mechanical properties?
Could we do something about
the mechanical properties?
And by the way, if those
are the things that
dictate whether a
glass forms or not,
then those are the
things that you
might think we might try to
engineer if we want to change
the properties of glass.
You can imagine I'm a silica--
oh, you got to pass this out.
I'm a big silicate,
an SiO4, and I'm
connected to these
other silicate groups
through this shared bridged
oxygen. And I'm a bulky thing,
and I'm trying to move around in
the liquid, crystal complexity.
I'm cooling down, and I'm
trying to move around.
And [INAUDIBLE] told
me to go that way,
but it's actually over there,
or there's no building there
and I don't know where to go.
Where is the lattice site?
It's complicated.
Glass could form.
Or maybe I'm a silicate
group and I'm like, hey,
could you please
get out of my way?
You're really
slowing things down,
you other silicate group
that I'm attached to.
Viscous, get out of my way.
No, I can't, viscous.
Or maybe you're a silicate
group and you're cooling down
and you're like,
that was very sudden.
I didn't even realize
that happened.
All of a sudden I'm
supposed to be a solid?
This is what's happening.
And so instead of getting into
this beautiful quartz crystal
it doesn't get there.
It doesn't get there.
A supercooled liquid
wants to be a solid.
It wants to, but it can't for
some reason, for some reason
that has to do with those.
So let's just have
this in our hands
while we're listening and
thinking about things,
and let me just tell
you about this one way--
if I take a piece of glass--
if I take a piece of
glass, and now imagine
that I take some part of
it, like this part here.
And in this part I'm
going to cool faster,
and in this part here
I'm going to cool slower.
So imagine it's a slab of glass,
and it's like the edges are
cooled at a different rate.
That's actually exactly
why a car window,
if you look at it through
polarized glasses,
has spots on it.
Those spots, some of
you may have seen these.
Those spots are changes,
purposeful changes
in the mechanical properties
of the glass to keep you safe.
Why?
If you call it slower, then
you might have some volume
that you want.
The volume here, let's call
this Vb and let's call this Va.
That goes along with the
graph we used before, b and a.
So it wants V--
what did I do-- b.
This wants Va.
But look at what happens.
If I purposely cool the
top really fast or maybe
I make spots that I cool
fast, then what happens?
Well, this wants to
have volume a inside.
This wants to have volume--
well, this cools first.
So this cools first.
So inside, so what happens?
As I cool it now, I have this.
This is now a glass.
This is now a solid.
And I should say glass
solid, so it's solidified.
And this wants to
have a lower volume--
lower volume.
It wants a lower
volume, but that's
been frozen at a higher volume.
Why?
I cooled it faster.
That's it.
I cooled it faster, and now the
inside is like, wait a second,
I'm not cooling so fast.
I don't need such a high volume.
Can I please get a smaller
volume out of this?
And the top is like,
well, I'm already stuck.
I'm already a solid.
And what happens is it pulls.
And so what you get is
wants lower volume pulls
on the surface, and that
means that this is going
to be the top, if I'll
just draw it one more time,
will be under compression--
under compression,
and the inside
will be under tensile stress--
under tensile stress.
You can kind of
imagine this, right?
You can see it.
I've frozen the top
because of cooling rate.
It's right here.
I just cooled the top faster.
The inside isn't cold yet.
It starts to cool, and
it tries to solidify
at a different volume.
It pulls it in.
But see, that changes
the mechanical properties
of the surface.
That's called tempering.
That's called tempered glass.
This is tempered glass, and
there is no better example
of temporal glass than the
Prince Rupert's drop, which is
the demo that Peter has come.
Here's Peter.
There's Peter
blowing some glass.
This is what he does
in his free time.
He just throws these big
glass-bowling parties.
He also happens to be the
director of the glass lab,
like I said.
He also teaches the classes,
the glass-blowing classes.
There's one for
freshmen during IAP,
and there's another
one in the spring.
They're very popular.
But because you're in
3091, he'll get you in.
He doesn't like it when I say
that because it's not true.
[LAUGHTER]
But come talk to him.
He's right here, and I think
you've got a demo for us.
So I'm going to let
Peter take the stage
and show you the best example
of tempered glass you can do.
And if you want to use the mic--
if you want to talk.
--a little kit out
And one year
Professor Cima, when
he was teaching this
class, told the class
that they had to come to the
lottery for the glassblowing
class, and it's a big class.
And so dutifully everyone
came to the lottery,
and we already have about
150 students plus 3091.
And the lottery
was in room 6120,
so we overflowed it by a lot.
So I told Michael, don't
ever do that again, please.
Which is why I do it every year.
But we like 3091 students.
We'll try to give
them preference.
[LAUGHTER]
Trying to work it for you.
He says that.
How many of you have seen
Prince Rupert drops before?
Some people, yeah.
There's a lot of online
stuff about them,
but you get to see
a live one today.
So what's the difference
between a Prince Rupert drop
and tempered glass like
the type [INAUDIBLE]??
Anybody want to take
a guess at that?
They're both under
stress, but the stress
is generated in a different way.
So the dots that were
on that windshield
are formed by air coolant.
That's how tempered
glass is made.
It goes through what's called
a [? lear ?] or a rolling
conveyor, and it's heated
up very, very quickly,
and then it's
cooled very quickly.
And it's cooled by this
array of compressed air jets
on both sides that take it
from almost the transition
temperature--
it just about wants
to move but doesn't
quite, down to room temperature
in three minutes or so.
And that super-rapid cooling
is what generates that stress
on the--
the difference
between the inside
and the outside
temperature in the glass.
And so it's air cooled,
but Prince Rupert
drop is cooled by--
anyone want to guess?
Water.
Yeah, by water.
So water is a better
coolant, right?
So as a result, you
get a lot more stress
embodied with the glass,
a lot more stress.
And so that's
relevant because you
don't want to make a window that
breaks with that kind of energy
and so you get explosive
energy all over the place.
So tempered glass is
engineered to fail.
It's very strong,
but it's engineered
to fail so that when it breaks,
it breaks into small pieces
so that if you're walking along
the sidewalk and a skyscraper
blows out a window, you don't
get huge shards of glass
falling down and hurting people.
You get little pellets
gently raining down,
which isn't such a bad thing.
[LAUGHTER]
So I've got two kinds of Prince
Rupert drops that I made here
and a vessel in which
to demonstrate here.
So first I'm going to show you--
they both cool rather quickly,
but one was cooled in air.
One was cooled in water.
This is the one
that's cooled in air.
And by the way, I used to
give a demo in the Glass Lab
where I would take the
Prince Rupert drop,
put it on a sealed table
that we call the marver,
and hit it with a hammer
as hard as I could.
I was never able to shatter
this head with a hammer.
In fact, I dented the
marver so many times
that I stopped doing that demo.
So I have a different way
of doing it now which is--
I won't do that today,
but usually I'll
have a student come and try
to break the Prince Rupert
drop in their hands.
It's really hard to do.
Most people can't do it.
But the air-cooled
Prince Rupert drop
doesn't have the same
kind of strength.
So watch what happens.
Not much.
Well, let's try down farther.
Maybe there's more stress there.
Nope, not [INAUDIBLE].
Let me try one more time.
Maybe where it's thicker maybe
there will be more stress.
Maybe a little.
So, here's the one
that's water cooled.
OK, don't blink.
Five, four, three, two, one.
That's the speed
of sound in glass,
which is, I think, about three
times faster than the speed
of sound in air.
So you can't see it.
But there is some great
high-speed video--
maybe some of you have
seen that online--
of Prince Rupert
drops exploding.
And actually up in
the Edgerton Center
they have a camera
that can catch that,
and they've got some
really cool video.
I'm going to leave this.
This is a very
cool fragment that
shows the fracture, the
failure pattern, which
is really interesting.
It fails from the
center of the drop
radially out at an
angle that looks
to be about a 45-degree angle.
You can probably explain that.
That will be on
the quiz tomorrow.
[LAUGHTER]
45 degree [INAUDIBLE]?
Was there a question?
I'm going to do one more
just in case anybody blinked,
and then I'm going
to be on my way.
By the way, Jeff
mentioned that we
had an IAP pass that starts
during IAP for freshmen
and a spring class that's open
to everybody at the institute.
So if you're not a freshman,
you can come to the lottery.
The lottery is for
all of our classes,
are shown on the
Glass Lab website.
And I think we're
going to be doing
the lottery for the spring
for the IAP class in November
late this month, and then the
spring class will probably
be sometime in January,
and it starts in March.
OK, ready?
Five, four, three, two, one.
[INAUDIBLE] will even
have some more energy.
Thanks, Peter.
[APPLAUSE]
That was awesome,
and I actually do
have a high-speed video of it,
so I'll show that to you now.
And again, so if you have
questions about glass,
if you want to watch--
Peter can make animals for
you, I think, on request.
Oh, this guy.
But anyway, thanks a lot,
Peter, for coming by.
As you know, I'm a big believer
in hands on, seeing things.
Can we pass-- is this--
no.
Well, your call.
Just don't eat it.
So now you know on parent's
day, when we have parents here,
we had the two sheets of glass.
One is called annealed.
It just means it's not
tempered, and the baseball
was supposed to break it.
It didn't.
Peter's got very
good annealed glass.
He's the one that gave
us those big sheets.
And it breaks into these
huge, dangerous shards.
Thanks, Peter.
Take care.
Oh yeah, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
If you notice, the tempered
glass, we tried to break it.
It also doesn't break.
It was supposed to be the
only one that didn't break.
But then you take a
little hammer at the edge
and you just lightly tap
the edge and the whole thing
breaks.
Why?
Because it's got so
much built-in stress.
It's got all this
compressive stress,
and the edge isn't
protecting that.
The edge of that tempered glass
isn't protecting the stress.
So when I just dig
in a little bit,
it's able to all crack
and release that stress.
So that's what
happened on family day.
Here's a high-speed video.
These are two guys from Corning.
And we can listen to this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
They're actually pretty cool.
- So there's a few
things going on here.
The cold water rapidly cools the
exterior surface of the glass,
hardening it almost immediately.
The interior, still
molten, cools more slowly.
As it cools, it contracts and
attempts to pull the surface
in with it, but it can't--
well, not very much.
The surface has
already hardened,
so it gets pulled in only
a little, compressing it,
while also creating an internal
layer that remains forever
under tension.
It is this action
that gives the glass
its uncharacteristic strength.
We call it compressive strength.
- It sounds like
the same principle
as how an arch provides strength
in structural engineering.
- Yes, kind of.
Now, Jamie, I'm going
to ask for your help.
We're going to attempt to
destroy this Prince Rupert
drop.
I just want you to tip that
hammer past its center point.
Go ahead.
That's what Peter
was talking about.
So you can hit it really hard.
- Now I feel like
we've been swindled.
- Swindled not.
We have just experienced--
That's good writing.
- --the power of
compressive strength.
It does, however,
have an Achilles heel.
Take those nippers right
there and nip the backside
of the tail of this
Prince Rupert drop
and watch what happens.
Wait, wait, wait, cue
the high-speed camera.
OK, here we go.
- Oh!
Here it comes.
- That was even cooler
than I thought it would be.
[END PLAYBACK]
So that's what
you just saw live.
And what that is is
it's a relief of--
thank you, or not.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, sure.
As Peter said, tempered
glass like in your car,
it's done with air cooling.
That's literally what
those circles are.
If you cool it even faster--
bam, faster cooling.
You now know, what does
faster cooling mean?
Well, if it's going
to form a glass
you might be all the way
near the melting point,
and you're going to have an
even-higher volume per mole
which is going to cause even
more stress within the glass
which is going to
make the surface very
strong because it's
all compressed,
but it's also going to
have a lot of energy in it
that it wants to release.
Let's see.
We were here on
Monday, and because I
was talking about other ways
to change the properties--
in fact, remember, I showed you
a couple of different examples
of glass, right, a glass
cup and a glass bottle,
and it turns out there
is not just silica in it.
There's all these
other things in it,
and there's many,
many kinds of glass.
And I listed a few here.
This was from Monday,
so I'm showing it again.
And going all the way back
to glass made in ancient Rome
you'll find that it's got
these other ingredients.
Why?
So that's what I want
to talk about next.
Well, let's use this.
So if you notice--
and this is where
we left off Monday--
if you notice something
like calcium oxide, well,
it's going to go
to Ca2+ and O2-.
Let's look at Na2O.
Na2O is going to
go 2Na+ plus O2-.
How about alumina?
That's on there, Al2O3.
Well, that's going to
go to 2Al3+ plus 3O2-.
Notice a pattern.
The pattern is you get O2-.
We can understand
why O2- minus has
been used, why
chemistry has been
used to change the properties
of glass for millennia.
And the reason goes
back to the pictures
that we drew on Monday
where we started
by talking about the chemistry
of the silicate group.
So remember Si?
Remember this?
An SiO4 is happy if it's
got four minus charges.
Remember that?
We started with Lewis and
it satisfies the octet.
But then in glass what
happens is you bridge.
And so you have this.
And I won't draw all of them.
I'll just draw it the
way we drew it before.
And you have these bridges,
and all of these oxygens
are bridges in glass.
So now I'll say, well,
what if I wanted--
and remember, these are forming
these long, viscous chains.
What if I wanted to make them
flow a little more easily?
What if I wanted them
to form shorter chains?
What if I wanted
to cut the pasta?
Don't do it in Italy.
They'll get really upset.
But Americans are OK with it.
If you need to cut the pasta,
it's OK in this country.
But if I need to cut the pasta
in chemistry and it's glass
that I'm cutting,
O2- is my knife.
It's my chemical scissors.
Chemical scissors, I like
that-- chemical scissors.
Why?
Well, you can see
because I go back.
What did the oxygen do?
By bridging it didn't
need that extra electron.
But if I bring now
something like Na2O--
so I've got an O2-.
Now I'm going to add an O2-.
Then what will happen is
you're going to cut this.
So now I'll just draw the--
I'll see if I can--
OK, so now I've added not just
an oxygen atom but the two
charges that each of them needed
before they bridged, you see,
to be happy?
And so now this can have
one of those charges,
and over here you
can have another one,
and so on and so on.
But see, now I've cut.
I've cut the glass pasta,
and I've done it chemically
and I've done it
from understanding
of octet and Lewis,
from basic chemistry
principles that we've learned.
Where's the sodium go?
Well, they'll be like a sodium.
They'll want to hang
out close by these.
There will be these
ions in there.
These sodium ions will
be in there still, right?
If it was Na2O, if
it's something else
and it's a different kind of
ion that might be leftover,
but the main thing is I've
delivered the chemistry
needed to cut this.
And this is called
chain scission.
There's a term for it, chain
scission, the technical term
for cutting glass pasta.
Well, this is powerful.
This is very powerful
because if I can cut this--
those are the silicate
groups, right?
And if I can cut them, then I
can change another property.
Look, I can change
the viscosity.
I've hit another one of those
three reasons why glass forms.
And so I'll show you a
slide in a minute that
shows you the change
in the viscosity,
but just to give you a
sense of what can happen,
how does that impact?
How does that impact?
Well, for silica crystal,
the melting point
is greater than 1,200 C. For Tg
of soda-lime glass, it's 500 C.
So you can imagine now
I've got another mechanism.
I've got another way,
not just processing,
not just cooling
rate, but chemistry
to mess with this curve.
Because you can
imagine now that I
might be able to get to lower
and lower transition points.
You see this?
I might be able to get to lower
and lower transition points
if these things can move faster
and not get locked into a solid
as easily if I add more and
more of these chemical scissors.
So maybe this one, now instead
of being cooled slower, maybe
this one had more
soda than this one.
Maybe now they're
cooled at the same rate
but I've changed the
amount of impurities,
the amount of oxygen, O2- very
specifically, that I've put in.
So it's another way now
to change this curve.
Now, these are called--
the thing that forms
the glass-- and we're
really only talking about
silica as our glass.
You can make other types of
glass not made from silica.
We're talking about
silica in this class.
So silicon is the atom that
is making those long spaghetti
strands, and it's called
the network former.
Silicon is called
And then the thing
that I put in there--
the thing that I put in there
that modified the network
is called the network modifier.
So you can see on this
graph that what you've got
is your bridging,
the bridging there
that's going between
two network formers.
And then you've got
these atoms that
are hanging out near a place
where you've broken a bridge.
So those would be modifiers.
Those are called
network modifiers.
These are just terms that
you will hear and see
when you think about glass--
network formers,
network modifiers.
The chemistry that you introduce
is modifying the network,
and it's what is done in
many, many different ways
with many, many
different [INAUDIBLE]
to change the
properties of glass.
And so here's the
curve that shows
you another kind of important
way of looking at this.
And I don't need you to
remember all of these terms,
but I want to show
you because this
is how glass is engineered.
Remember, today the topic is
how do we change the properties?
We talked about
the cooling rate.
Now we're talking
about adding chemicals.
And so now you're going
to work with the glass
to do something with it.
If you're going to do that,
this is one of the first plots
you'll look up.
And it shows you-- it
plots the temperature.
This really doesn't
work at all--
the temperature on one axis--
so that's like the x-axis--
and on the y-axis is the
viscosity because now
that's the property that we're
changing, right, the viscosity?
So there's silica up
on the upper right.
Can you see that?
So fused silica, that's
basically almost quartz.
That's basically quartz.
So you are really close
to making a nice crystal,
but notice how high of viscosity
you have versus temperature.
Notice that you're at this very,
very high value for viscosity.
It's a really thick material.
And people care a
lot about viscosity
when they work with glass.
Why?
Because you need to
know, for example,
is the viscosity at a point
where I can work with it?
Can I shape it?
That's the bottom.
That's the region that
says working range.
I can still shape it.
I can make a window.
There it flows under
its own weight.
So now I can shape it and
it will lose the shape.
That's kind of important to know
if I'm making a glass animal.
There its stress can
still be relieved.
Remaining stress can
still be relieved,
and up there you
can rapidly cool it
without introducing new defects.
But look at the tradeoff
between the temperature
that you have to go to and the
viscosity and the viscosity
that you have.
So if you go now from
this almost quartz
all the way down--
OK, there you take a little
bit of stuff and you put it in,
but it's still 96% silica.
And now you go to
boiled silicate.
Remember, it's like 75%, 80%
silica plus other additives.
And look at how much you've
changed the temperature.
So I can now work
with this material
below 1,000 C. That has huge
consequences for industry,
for actually making
different things out
of glass, which we
now do regularly.
And the Romans did it too,
but they didn't know why.
They said, well, if you add
a little bit of this dirt,
something different happens.
Let's try a little
bit of that one.
Now we know.
We know why.
And so this curve
now is something
that we understand and we
understand how to control it.
And if you go back to the
example of making glass tough,
I was just showing you these
ions, these sodium ions.
They're left in there.
Well, it turns out that you
can put ions into glass,
and maybe you're doing it
to change the viscosity
so the thing stays
liquid for longer,
and you can maybe work with
it in different regimes.
But maybe you're putting
the ions in there
to do something else.
And so actually there's
a whole another thing
you can do once you have ions
in the glass like sodium.
You can substitute them out.
Imagine that I
have-- that's what
this next picture is showing.
Imagine that I've
got a glass in here,
and those red
circles are sodium.
But now I've introduced a
different ion on the surface.
That's potassium.
What happens?
Well, if I have a high
concentration of potassium
and I put it on a
surface of glass that
has a bunch of
sodium in it, so now
I've got a glass with
sodium ions in it.
And I expose it to
a potassium bath.
So now I've got
potassium up here.
And what happens is if the
concentration is high enough
and the conditions are
right, I can get potassium
to go in for the sodium.
And so actually now
I can substitute.
So these were here.
I can now substitute
those for potassium.
Well, but this is a big
deal because potassium
is bigger than sodium.
And so if I am able to on
the surface, let's say,
put something bigger
in there, then you
can imagine that it's
pushing the other stuff
into each other.
That's causing the same stress.
K+ plus bigger than sodium, and
this causes this huge surface
tension.
Same principle as tempering,
but now I've done it chemically.
This is Gorilla Glass.
This is all phone screens.
This is what they do because
you can get really, really
hard glass this way.
And if you go back to these
guys, they have a little--
and this is just a
very short video.
They've got this sort of longer
videos on the Corning website
that talk about this,
and they shoot bullets
through Gorilla Glass.
You can make glass
really strong with just
chemical substitutions, and
all you're thinking about
is atom size.
Because by putting
this larger atom in,
you cause this same kind
of compressive stress
at the surface.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Gorilla Glass, it's
been refined over time,
but like all Gorilla Glass
variants that came before it,
it is compressive-strength
glass.
But it's not made in the same
way as we just demonstrated,
the rapid-cooling method.
No, instead Corning uses
an ion-exchange process.
To break it down
simply, the surface ion
particles that naturally
form during the manufacture
are replaced with
larger ion particles.
Once exchanged, the
larger ion particles
create the same sort
of inward pressure
that we see on the
Prince Rupert drop.
And with this method they are
able to control and manage
the resulting--
[END PLAYBACK]
The resulting what?
What was he going to say?
I don't know actually.
I don't remember.
I have to go watch it now.
So that's just a
video showing you
what I just showed you,
which is that that's yet
another way of engineering
the properties of glass,
and there are so many more.
One of the points I
want to make today
about how to engineer
glass-- so we're talking
about how to change this curve.
Maybe we change the
viscosity by adding O2
which changes the curve here.
Maybe we change
the cooling rate.
Maybe I can use additives,
ions in different ways.
But it turns out
that we have come
to a place where we can
engineer every single one
of these properties.
We can make conducting glass,
even though it's usually
been and usually is insulating.
We can make chemically
active glass.
As you just saw, we can change
the mechanical properties.
There are now flexible
rolls of glass
that look literally like Saran
wrap almost, but they're glass.
And so it all comes
down to the pasta.
And so where we are, if
we use the pasta analogy--
which as you, I think, can
understand I really like
because I really like pasta.
This is a great
analogy for glass
because it's like
in the Roman time,
all we had was one
sauce, everything.
Just mix it all in--
meatballs, pesto,
red sauce, carbonara.
I can go on.
And that's all they did.
They just didn't know why
things were happening.
But now that we know about the
electronic structure of atoms,
we can make glass into any
delicious pasta dish we want,
right?
OK, don't eat it, but
you know what I mean.
And so I'll give you
a couple of examples.
So the point is the
last 20 centuries,
we were really just
getting warmed up
when it comes to this material.
What the recent understanding
of how to engineer this material
has led to are real
breakthrough ideas.
And so I'll show you just a
couple in my why this matters.
Because glass is, after
all, made of-- there
it is up there in
case you can't see it.
This is the abundance of
elements versus atomic number,
and you notice the
very top two elements
are silicon and oxygen. And so
it would be really nice if we
could make a lot of
stuff out of these really
abundant cheap elements.
Think sand.
Could I take sand and make
a lot of stuff out of it?
Well, not if I can't control.
Not if I have to heat it up to
3,000 degrees or its viscosity
isn't what I want or it doesn't
give me the properties I want,
but that has changed.
That has fundamentally changed.
So we can now look at
materials like this,
these super-abundant materials,
and we can completely
rethink them.
And I'll give you one example.
It's already a few
years old, but I
think it's just a
really cool idea, which
is called the Solar Sinter.
And here he's
developed this machine
that is entirely solar powered.
They're solar cells
for the electricity.
And it's a focused beam
of light from the sun that
gets hot enough to
engineer the glass.
So he takes sand from
the desert that he's in.
He puts it in a container,
and he's got a 3D printer
that he's made.
It's entirely solar powered.
There's no fossil fuels, but
he can take sand and turn it
into something structural.
And so there's a
vase that he's made,
and you can take that out.
And again, that's
just the beginning
of rethinking what we could
do with these super-abundant
materials.
Here's an example from also a
few years ago from an MIT lab.
This is Neri Oxman's lab, and
she's in the Mediated Matter
lab here at MIT, and she's
developed a 3D printer.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYBACK]
And so there it is printing
something with glass.
And she can print lots of
different designs now using
glass.
She has a cool video.
And there is the printhead.
And again, 1,900 Fahrenheit.
I'm not sure that I
want a 1,900 Fahrenheit
printer on my desktop.
But as you can imagine,
what they had to do--
I'll just give you one more
example and then we'll stop.
What they had to do is
understand everything
we've just talked about.
How do you engineer the
viscosity, the melting point
to make it all work
in a 3D printer?
The last point I'll
give you is this.
I love this.
This is from a few years ago.
It's a group in Japan
that made a glass that
is as strong as steel.
And what they talk about--
this is what I like.
They say just think of a world
where your smartphone wouldn't
shatter.
OK, cool.
Buildings could be bolstered
against natural disasters, even
cooler.
And then somehow
they bring it down.
Wine glasses are
reassuringly safe.
[LAUGHTER]
Was that really a problem?
I don't know.
And what they did,
fabrication was
conducted using an aerodynamic
levitation furnace where
ingredients were floated
in the air using oxygen gas
and melted together
using CO2 lasers,
and they get a transparent
superglass with 50% alumina.
That was so hard to do
because the aluminum didn't
want to be a glass.
It wanted to go and
become a metal, a crystal.
But by doing it
this way, they were
able to capture it
in the disorder.
All right, have a great night.
See you guys on Friday.